you and I have a very odd relationship
and I want a clue the listeners in I
want to say I Met You in was it 95 96
2002.
[Music]
what am I thinking of
um who am I thinking of you're looking
at me I didn't know you then I must have
known someone else I thought I knew you
a lot longer than that no a bunch of the
Chicago writers had come to your late
night show back in the 90s
um but I've never even been to New York
till 2002. you first arrived in New York
City in 2002 yeah okay
I didn't do any research for this no you
are
which guy is he that's Jack oh Jack
McBrayer Jack I just said it
a lot of people say they're Jack McQueen
this guy Jack McBrayer oh touche
I've known you since let's say 2002. you
come to New York and I've known you
that's still a long time not as long as
I thought I knew you I really thought I
knew you since 95 but that's clearly
someone else I'm thinking of but
that's a long time and I don't think and
I'm being honest here that you and I
have ever had a long real conversation
no you might be right
um yeah now what do you think the
problem is you yeah it's not him yeah
100 well hold on let's get to something
straight first of all I'll describe what
I what I do which is
um hold on let me just sorry let me get
to this particular type of abuse because
it's important to be clear Jack I always
uh we go into I go into schtick where
you are the country rube and I am the
cruel uh City Slicker and we've been
doing this since I met you and uh you've
been to my house many times yes invited
yeah yeah I know I know and we've spent
hours and hours together we're never I'm
never real and part of the problem and I
just want to say this to Matt and Sona
is that he is so good at playing his
part yes you always go into sir I did
well please sir you are wrong sir and
that keep keeps me going you have to
admit that you it's victim blaming yes
yeah yeah if that is victim blaming oh
that's your contribution to that
argument
that is victim blaming uh I don't know
what law school you went to
um repeat with emphasis law I I have to
tell you excuse me they said thank you
and I agree he repeated with emphasis
there you go so we've known each other a
long time and this is the kind of stuff
that we do it's fun and
um I ran into mutual friend Mr John Hamm
just the other day and what did we talk
about Ian yes about the time you came
backstage at one of my shows and I had a
guitar on strapped on and
um I was doing my wait wait wait it's
Jack McBrayer schtick and you were
saying sir please sir no sir and then I
started to Play Dueling Banjos theme
on the guitar and you started to clog
dance against your will
Jon Hamm was chuckling about that memory
and I remember
that because it showed up in a
documentary a Critic acting as for the
New York Times saying this is terrible
Conan it's his cruel side came out and
he Force checked dance as if you have no
control over what you do when someone
plays Dueling Banjos but that has been
our Dynamic yes
I don't know I did feel bullied then oh
here it is
Hey listen I don't
nice
to try and have a real conversation with
you get to the real Jack McBrayer not
any of our old Shenanigans where I role
play so let's go through I do have
research on the real you you that's true
I do
you were born in corn cob Georgia okay
thank you for having me this was a lot
of fun
none of this when you first came to the
big city was on that bus and you had a
cardboard suitcase when you disembarked
in New York did you or did you not step
off the bus and go garsh they sure made
these buildings real tall where did you
research this you called an elevator a
moving room for six years
around between the time I got on and I
got off it's completely different sir is
this true none of this is true cardboard
suitcase that's a box
I think I have the facts on my side you
refused to go on 30 Rock for a while
because you were afraid those cameras
would capture your spirit true or false
way false extremely false you said to
Tina Fey and this is a quote I'm gonna
want my spirit back no
no no the opposite no
no
no I'm a the car that you drove here in
is made of husks they were woven
together
true or false very false there's not a
corn cob car
hey I'm just gonna make a sort of
symbolic button and if any time you
press that you can tag out and I'll just
go to town someone here oh yeah yeah oh
yeah oh I'm real scared yeah
I'm just gonna get brutal so that's just
there if you need it okay if at any
point the baby lamb gets scared of the
tiger he's gonna tap out and the wounded
black cap chickadee
is gonna leave its nest and come after
me
unbelievable